uh
one guy who is a very excellent weapon
in an nfl offense deandre hopkins and
we've been
curious about what went wrong in houston
to cause the texans to trade him away on
a deal that universally has been
regarded as a bad deal for the texans i
think about it chris nobody agrees on
anything in this day and age everyone
agrees the texans got screwed in the
deandre hopkins deal so what went on
michael irvin was on espn's first take
earlier today and he said he spoke to
the andre hopkins and among other things
hopkins was offended by some things that
coach bill o'brien had said to him
called him in for a meeting individually
said i haven't had to have a meeting
like this since aaron hernandez which is
a hell of a name to invoke made comments
about deandre hopkins having multiple
baby mamas i mean it just sounds like
this is something that's been
percolating for a while we've had this
conversation chris that last year bill
o'brien wanted to trade deandre hopkins
former gm brian gaine did not right and
they held on to him for another year but
man this sounds poisonous now i'm seeing
that deandre hopkins is claiming that
michael irvin is blowing things out of
proportion shocker michael irvin is not
a reliable scrivener and relayer of
factual information from a phone call uh
and it could be that hopkins doesn't
want to have that that that
you know that label on him of being a
troublemaker per se yep but uh look
something happened to cause the texans
to cut and run the way they did and take
what seems like a hell of a lot less
than they could have gotten for one of
the best receivers in the game yeah well
they're certain i mean we've been
hearing about it yeah i mean you're to
what you said you're right i mean we've
been hearing about this for a year i
mean maybe more than that really about
you know there's just not there's not a
cohesiveness uh cohesiveness there
between the two first off you know i
know deandre hopkins have had him on my
podcast have hung out with him for a day
in new york city did all that i love him
i really do i mean i think he's a
competitor he's a good person he's
fearless i really do bill bill o'brien
you know he's he's an army general you
know and he's he's new england-ish that
way so he's never easy on anybody
you know i don't necessarily like those
things that you hear that billy o'brien
might have said to deandre hopkins i can
certainly see that offending any player
let alone one of your stars on your
football team i will say this though i
don't think
that the houston texans got fleeced in
this deal as much as everybody's trying
to make it out to be listen if you don't
if your evaluation and you don't think
deandre hopkins is worth being paid 22
million dollars a year and then also
your evaluation takes you to think oh i
like what i see on film from david
johnson and i think he's still a top
tier running back in football and you
got a second round pick i know it's not
perfect but i think the ultimate thing
here more than anything where the texans
knew they were going to lose leverage
and maybe they had a sense it was going
to happen this off season that hopkins
was going to draw a line in the sand and
be like i'm not coming back until i get
22 million dollars a year and be for
that then it's not necessarily that bad
of a trade altogether and mike we hit on
this the other day too we got to keep in
mind i mean we know patrick mahomes is
going to sign a new contract here soon
deshawn watson is the next guy the next
guy up i mean he's going to command
he if deshawn watson was in the contract
negotiations right now i would have no
problem going make desean watson the
highest paid player in the history of
football that's what kind of talent he
is i mean he's just about to hit the
prime of his career too the only guy you
can look here right now and just go oh
maybe they have a brighter future to me
is patrick mahomes other than that he's
a superstar so they had to balance that
out and i think that's why it might not
look as good the public but i don't
think it's as bad as everybody's trying
to make it to be at least in my opinion
and the window is as open for desean
watson to get his new deal as it is for
patrick mahomes nobody's talking about
that and you know the texans have
a mixed history of how they handle their
first-round picks who become star
players when it's time to pony up the
cash j.j watt got his second contract
after three seasons j'davion clowney
never got his desean watson may have to
wait another year but you're right you
can't give deandre hopkins julio jones
money by the way hopkins and jones
represented by the same agency caa you
can't give him julio jones money if
you're getting ready to pay watson and
as we said earlier in the week in
arizona they're two years away from kyle
murray even being in a position right to
expect a new contract so you know
there's a report that the eagles
considered hopkins but he wants too much
money
the the patriots were part of the
conversation and i think anyone who
trades for him knows you're signing on
to a problem contractually if you're not
ready to pay him what he wants that's
right and i think the cardinals are they
wouldn't have done the deal so you're
right that's part of this you're getting
rid of a headache financially yeah and
if you're also getting rid of a headache
for the head coach right or wrong right
or wrong right if bill o'brien has
decided this isn't one of my guys and
it's a negative presence in the locker
room that is working against what i'm
trying to do then then you got to move
on yeah but but still it is amazing to
me see here's the problem this is where
pr comes into play right right if you've
got that message to send and you're the
texans you better get that message out
there otherwise everybody's going to
look at it and say
billy i don't know what the hell he's
doing he keeps getting fleeced on all of
these trades at some point and look i
respect a guy who doesn't give a crap
yeah at some point you have to give a
crap because at some point perception is
reality and the perception is that bill
o'brien is so far over his skis as a gm
he doesn't even know he's got skis on
that's the problem yeah well i listen i
i understand that i i get where people
are being critical there uh and you know
also too we just got to remember yeah
you're right you you got to respect
billy oh because he's one of those guys
he just he doesn't give a crap you're
right it's dangerous to play that game
this day and age because you're right
the perception does become reality but
he's a new england guy and as we know
just like belichick
they just don't give a damn what the
rest of the world thinks they're
convicted in their their their studies
their knowledge everything there we know
he's a tough sob bilio he really is he's
a no-nonsense in-your-face football
coach i really respect that about him
and yeah we'll see what he's made of his
gm i know one thing he's a damn good
head coach that's the one thing i know
you know he went to the playoffs with
some quarterbacks the last few years
where i just go damn these these guys
aren't even in football anymore these
guys aren't worth the damn and he took
the team to the playoffs still so you
know i don't want to be too critical but
yeah you're i hear people's concerns
with the the clowney trade the hopkins
trade uh i understand how that could be
hard to swallow for for texans fans
and and see that's the challenge if
you're gonna be the gm and you don't
have any pelts on the wall and or
pellets on the horse you better care
what people think yeah and you better
control the narrative or the narrative
controls you and you're not bill
belichick yet billy oh because you
haven't won anything if you want
something you cannot care but i'm
telling you bill o'brien if you're
watching this i want you to succeed
you're not going to succeed if you sit
back and let the story carry you you've
got to carry the story
agreed agreed
that's part of the game in the nfl as we
all know and you're right there's only
one guy in football that can get away
with it right now and he's up in new
england with the initials bb yep he can
do it he can treat us all like jerks
tell us to shut up give us no answers it
doesn't matter because the pellets are
on the horse with him he's got you know
six of them and a bunch of other things
to go along with it to say hey screw you
none of you know as much as i do so f
off
and and look at it this way i mean he
basically stiff arm tom brady yeah and
nobody's saying boo about it no and it's
clear that belichick didn't want him now
belichick didn't come out and say he
didn't want him but the circumstances
point to tom brady realizing this guy
doesn't want me i'm going to leave and
no one's going to criticize bill
belichick for it because he's got the
rings you can be that way when you've
got the rings when you don't you better
worry about what people are saying and
you better do what you can to convince
them otherwise or the narrative locks in
and it will contribute to your downfall
if you don't win
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports